GREAT TO SEE YOU.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE ARE WITNESSING WHAT IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED EFFORT AROUND THE
COUNTRY FROM THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO
FUNDAMENTALLY RADICALLY
TRANSFORM THIS COUNTRY.
IN HIS FRAIL COGNITIVELY
STRUGGLING STATE, JOE BIDEN, THE
LEADER, MIGHT NOT REALIZE IT BUT
HIS ADMINISTRATION IS NOW WAGING
WHAT IS AN ALL-OUT ASSAULT ON
THE PRINCIPLES THAT HAVE MADE
THIS COUNTRY GREAT.
AS WE SPEAK, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW PLOTTING
A NEW COURT PACKING SCHEME TO
SEIZE CONTROL OVER THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, A COEQUAL
BRANCH.
THEY ARE EYEING STATEHOOD FOR
D.C., FOR PUERTO RICO TO
GUARANTEE FOUR NEW DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS IN PERPETUITY.
THEY ARE FEDERAL RISING
ELECTIONS AND PREVENT ALL FORMS
OF VOTER IDENTIFICATION.
THAT MEANS NO VOTER I.D.
WHATSOEVER.
HRS R1.
INCREASING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
WHAT?
FRAUD, ABUSE, NO INTEGRITY, NO
CONFIDENCE IN FUTURE ELECTIONS.
THAT WILL BE THE RESULTS.
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER SO THEY
CAN RAM THROUGH THIS RADICAL
AGENDA.
THEIR BILL THROUGH CONGRESS
WITHOUT ANY REPUBLICAN SUPPORT
AND THEIR POLICIES WILL SHRED
OUR CONSTITUTION STARTING WITH
THE WOKE CANCEL CULTURE
DESTROYING WHAT SEE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, PRETTY MUCH THE
ENTIRE DOCUMENT.
OF COURSE NONE OF THIS IS ABOUT
FREEDOM, LIBERTY, SECURITY OR
INNOVATION ARE MAKING YOUR LIFE
BETTER.
FOR THE LEFT, THIS IS ABOUT ONE
THING AND ONE THING ONLY.
DON’T LET ANYBODY CONVINCE YOU
OTHERWISE.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER.
POWER OVER OUR ELECTIONS.
POWER THAT FAVORS THEM.
POWER OVER OUR COURTS FOR FAVORS
THEM.
POWER OVER STATE LEGISLATURES
EVEN IF IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
POWER OVER STATE AND LOCAL LAW.
POWER OVER YOUR LIFE.
POWER INPUT OPPORTUNITY FOREVER
AND EVER.
HERE’S THE END GAME.
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY
ULTIMATELY WANTS ALL OF AMERICA
PRETTY MUCH TO RESEMBLE
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK.
HIGH TAXES, HIGH CRIME, HORRIBLE
SCHOOLS, BURDENSOME REGULATION,
MASSIVE GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION.
THIS IS THE DREAM.
THIS IS WHAT THEY TELL US.
IF YOU LIKE NEW YORK AND YOU
LIKE CALIFORNIA, BUCKLE UP
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT UNITED
SANCTUARY SOCIALIST STATES OF
AMERICA WILL LOOK LIKE.
IN NEW YORK CITY IF YOU ARE
PEACEFUL LAW-ABIDING TAXPAYING
CITIZEN, YOU BETTER NOT JAYWALK
OR GO 15 MILES OVER THE SPEED
LIMIT.
OR FORGET TO WEAR YOUR MASK OR
EXERCISE GOD FORBID YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
YOU’LL GO TO JAIL WITH PROBABLY
LITTLE HOPE OF EVER GETTING OUT.
LET A YOU’RE A VIOLENT CRIMINAL
UNFIT FOR SOCIETY,
NEW YORK STATE WELCOMES YOU WITH
OPEN ARMS.
YOU WANT TO LOOT.
YOU WANT TO ATTACK COPS?
YOU WANT TO LIGHT THE BUILDING
ON FIRE?
LET’S SEE.
THROW ROCKS AND BOTTLES AND
BRICKS, MOLOTOV COCKTAILS TOWARD
POLICE, WELL, YOU GET THE
GET-OUT-OF-JAIL-FREE CARD
LITERALLY.
THEIR NEW NO BAIL LAWS IN
NEW YORK.
IN FACT MANY OF THESE CRIMES ARE
NEVER EVEN PROSECUTED.
LAST YEAR A GUY ROB FOUR BANKS,
GOT ARRESTED, GOT RELEASED,
RIGHT BACK ONTO THE STREETS AND
THEN IMMEDIATELY GOES TO ROB
ANOTHER.
GET SCOTT, GETS RELEASED, THEN
ROBS ANOTHER ONE.
LAST NIGHT WE SHOWED YOU THIS
HORRIFIC VIDEO, MAN BRUTALLY
ASSAULTING A 65-YEAR-OLD WOMAN
THAT WAS WALKING TO CHURCH.
MIDTOWN MANHATTAN.
IT’S DAYLIGHT.
BY THE WAY, PUSHING HER TO THE
PAVEMENT.
WATCH THE FACE BEING STOMPED ON
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THE ALLEGED PERPETRATOR WAS OUT
ON PAROLE AFTER SPENDING ONLY 17
YEARS BEHIND BARS FOR MURDERING
HIS OWN MOTHER WITH A KNIFE.
WHY WAS HE EVER RELEASED?
MEANWHILE IN ITHACA NEW YORK,
YOU HAVE A CONVICTED COP KILLER.
THAT’S RIGHT, COP KILLER
CONVICTED.
RECENTLY PAROLED FROM PRISON.
NOW SITTING ON THE CITY’S POLICE
REFORM BOARD.
THAT’S JUST GENIUS.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE ALL WITNESSING SIMILAR
THINGS HAPPENING LIKE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS ALSO
OUTLAWED CASH BAIL FOR THOSE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD IT.
THE STATE HAS ALSO BEEN CUTTING
FUNDING FOR THE L.A.P.D.,
DOWNSIZING THE HARD-CORE GANGS
UNIT AND CALIFORNIA’S MORE
VIOLENT CRIME THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE NATION.
SO IF YOU LIKE CALIFORNIA, YOU
LIKE NEW YORK, YOU ARE GOING TO
LIVE BY AN SOCIALIST UTOPIA.
BY THE WAY, ALSO BOTH HER
SANCTUARY STATES MEANING THEY
SHIELD EVEN CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
EVEN THOSE THAT GET OUT OF JAIL
FOR VIOLENT CRIMES, THEY ARE
PROTECTED BY THE STATE FROM
DEPORTATION.
ENFORCING THE LAW OF THE LAND.
IF YOU ARE A LAW ABIDING CITIZEN
WITH NO CRIMINAL RECORD, WORK
HARD, PAY YOUR TAXES, WEIGHT
LOSS, TRYING TO FOLLOW THE
REGULATIONS, YOU BETTER MASCOT.
YOU BETTER FOLLOW ALL THE COVID
PROTOCOLS.
YOU BETTER GET ALL OF YOUR
REQUIRED PERMITS OR YOU’RE
PROBABLY GOING TO GO STRAIGHT TO
JAIL AND YOUR BUSINESS COULD BE
SHUT DOWN.
YOU CAN FACE SERIOUS LIFE
ALTERING CONSEQUENCES AND GOD
FORBID IF YOU WANT TO HOLD A
CHURCH SERVICE SOMEWHERE.
NOW UNLESS YOU’RE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM WHO IN THE
MIDDLE OF HIS STATES TO CONEY
AND LOCKDOWNS ENJOYED HIS MASK
LESS DINNER AT THAT FANCY
RESTAURANT WITH A LARGE GROUP OF
FRIENDS.
DOESN’T SEEM TOO DISTANT TO ME.
WHEN DEMOCRATS HAVE ALL THE
POWER THE RULES DON’T APPLY TO
THEIR MAGNIFICENT LEADERS.
THEY WILL DEFUND THE POLICE AND
THEN THEY HIRE ARMED GUARDS.
THEY WILL SHUT DOWN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BECAUSE OF COVID AND
SEND THEIR OWN KIDS TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS, JUST LIKE GAVIN NEWSOM.
THEY WILL BAN GUNS AND THEN
ENJOY THE SERVICE OF THEIR OWN
STATE BACKED PRIVATE SECURITY,
ARMED.
MAYBE THIS IS WHY EVERY SINGLE
CITY IN THE U.S. WITH A HIGH
RATE OF VIOLENT CRIME IS RUN BY
DEMOCRATS AND HAS BEEN FOR
DECADES.
WHEN ANY OF THEIR POLICIES
CREATE A MAJOR CRISIS LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE THE ONE THAT IS REAL OUT
OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
DEMOCRATS PRETEND IT’S NOT
HAPPENING OR THAT IT’S TOTALLY
OUT OF THEIR CONTROL.
THEN THEY ACCUSE ANYONE WHO
CRITICIZES THEM FOR BEING A
HEARTLESS MONSTER.
THOSE CONDITIONS FRANKLY ARE
HEARTLESS.
THAT THEY ARE PUTTING THESE KIDS
IN.
HERE’S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF ALL
THIS FROM TODAY’S PRESS
BRIEFING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HAS THE WHITE HOUSE
CONSIDERED BEEFING UP BORDER
SECURITY NOW THAT THERE IS VIDEO
OF A 3-YEAR-OLD AND A 5-YEAR-OLD
BEING THROWN OVER THE WALL IN
NEW MEXICO?
>> BEEFING UP BORDER SECURITY.
>> THERE IS VIDEO NOW OF A
3-YEAR-OLD AND A 5-YEAR-OLD.
>> I’VE SEEN THE VIDEO AND I
THINK ANY OF US WHO’VE SEEN THE
VIDEO WERE INCREDIBLY ALARMED BY
THE STEPS OF SMUGGLERS.
>> THEY STILL GOT CLOSE ENOUGH.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT ADDRESSING
ROOT CAUSES IN THE REGION.
THE SMUGGLERS THROUGH A CHILD
OVER THE WALL.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED MORE ABOUT
THE KIDS SAFETY OUR KIDS GETTING
ON.
TELL ME MORE ABOUT YOUR CONCERN.
>> KIDS SAFETY.
>> OF COURSE, I’M OFTEN
SURPRISED BY THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING.
>> Sean: CIRCLE BACK.
WHY ARE YOU SURPRISED?
LOOK AT THE KIDS BEING DROPPED
14 FEET UP IN THE AIR MAYBE YOU
AND THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT SHOULD’VE NOT
INVITED THOSE TO SEEK ASYLUM IN
THE UNITED STATES.
YOU’RE LETTING ALL THESE PEOPLE
IN AS WAS REPORTED BY 19 U.S.
SENATORS.
BY THE WAY WHAT ARE THE
CONDITIONS LIKE?
IF YOU COULD TELL THE PEOPLE
THAT THE BORDERS ARE CLOSE
TO.
LAWS WILL BE ENFORCED, THEY WILL
BE DEPORTED AND DEPORTED
IMMEDIATELY.
MAYBE FINISHING BUILDING
DONALD TRUMP’S WALL.
THEY MAY BE REINSTATE
DONALD TRUMP’S POLICY WHICH IS
TO STAY IN MEXICO.
GET RID OF CATCHER RELEASE.
BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT’S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN, IS IT?
DO YOU THINK THEY CARE THE KIDS
ARE BEING TOSSED OVER THE WALL.
IT’S HAPPENING BECAUSE THEY
CREATED THIS SCENARIO.
WHAT ABOUT THE KIDS AND BIDENS
CAGES?
DO YOU THINK THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT ANY OF THOSE CONDITIONS IN
THOSE MIGRANT DETENTION
FACILITIES?
YEP, JOE BIDEN JUST KEEPS
BUILDING MORE AND MORE GAUGES.
AS YOU CAN SEE IF YOU RAN A
DAY CARE CENTER, IF YOU RAN A
PRE-K CENTER AND THEY CAME IN
AND TOOK PHOTOS LIKE THAT, YOU
WOULD BE ARRESTED FOR CHILD
ABUSE.
NOW YOU THINK THEY CARE ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY RISKS?
THE VIOLENT CARTELS THAT ARE
MAKING MONEY.
THEY ARE MAKING A BUNDLE HAND
OVER FIST.
FOR DEMOCRATS IT’S NOTHING MORE
THAN A P.R. CRISIS ONLY AND IN
THE END, IT’S WORTH IT FOR THEM
APPARENTLY BECAUSE THEY DO
NOTHING TO SOLVE IT.
THEY WON’T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE IT
LIKE THEY DIDN’T ACKNOWLEDGE THE
RIOTS OVER THE SUMMER.
THE LEFT SEEMS TO BELIEVE THAT
OPEN BORDERS MEANS OH, MORE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
WE WILL GIVE THEM SOMETHING OF
GREAT VALUE, AMNESTY.
WE HOPE THEY VOTE FOR US.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PANDERING
FROM THE FIRST LADY.
>> WHEN WE COME TOGETHER, WE ARE
POWERFUL.
WITH LOVE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
WITH HOPE FOR OUR FUTURE, WITH
FAITH IN EACH OTHER, ANYTHING IS
POSSIBLE.
SO SAY IT WITH ME.
THE FUTURE IS OURS.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: NAILED IT.
EVERYTHING DEMOCRATS DO,
EVERYTHING THEY SAY, EVERY BILL
THEY ENACT OR THROUGH EXECUTIVE
FIAT IN THE STROKE OF A PEN,
EVERY GROUP THEY PANDER TO, IT’S
ALTHOUGH SHAMELESS ATTEMPT TO
USE YOUR MONEY SO THEY CAN GAIN
POWER HOPEFULLY IN THEIR MINDS
IN PERPETUITY.
BUCKLE UP.
YOU BETTER BRACE YOURSELF.
IF THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL, THIS
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISM LIKE EVERY
OTHER SOCIALIST EXPERIMENT
BEFORE, IT WILL FAIL.